me
the Southern Nevada Water Authority
wants other Western water districts just
to face reality and start conserving
precious resources in the face of what
is now a 20-year drought snwa feels it
is wasteful to grow certain water
intensive crops in parched desert
Landscapes but does the Water Authority
follow its own advice Chief 8 news now
investigator George Knapp has our story
I'll say in a in a word the answer is no
snwa is not following the advice that
it's handed out to other water agencies
in the west snwa has done a great job in
encouraging conservation of pressure
precious Water Resources by telling the
public to wise up and be water smart but
at the same time it's been pouring
precious water into a massive venture
California's Imperial Valley is a Bread
Basket where all manner of winter
vegetables are grown but a drive through
the valley makes it clear what grows
most of all field after field of thick
green Alfalfa it takes seven feet of
water to grow each acre of alfalfa all
of which is fed to animals and most of
which is exported to Asia especially to
China
this single District gets more Colorado
River water than the entire states of
Nevada and Arizona combined which is why
Nevada water officials have urged
changes in how water from the troubled
river is used well ordinarily I stay out
of my neighbor's business but when you
have a math problem and 80 percent of
the water use is in agriculture and 80
percent of that 80 percent is for forage
crops which are largely exported it's
hard not to see how that's not part of
the solution
Nevada ranchers and Farmers might want
to heed that advice water intensive
Alfalfa grown in the driest state in the
country is Nevada's second biggest
Agricultural Product after beef this
Ranch in White Pine County for example
is part of a seven property Empire that
stretches across more than 100 miles
north the South covering a vast 950 000
Acres overall who owns this sprawling
conglomerate you do the public the Great
Basin Ranch as it's known is owned and
operated by a public agency the Southern
Nevada Water Authority take a guess
what's the one and only crop grown on
snwa's vast ranching Empire in eastern
Nevada Alfalfa and a lot of it 8 600
tons of it last year why is a public
agency in the ranching business
competing directly against smaller
beleaguered Family Farms 15 years ago
snwa plunked down a whopping 79 million
dollars to buy seven ranches that at the
time were valued at one tenth that
amount the properties were intended as
beachheads for snwa's plan to build more
than 300 miles of pipes and pumps to
siphon billions of gallons of rural
groundwater and send it to Thirsty Las
Vegas cost estimates Grew From 1 billion
to 5 billion to 15 billion dollars
before snwa pulled it off the table the
plan was scrapped not because of the
expense but because opponents prevailed
in multiple Court battles arguing that
sucking an ocean of water from rural
aquifers would drain the water table and
create a huge dead zone
now years after the pipeline plan was
supposedly killed snwa is still pouring
public resources into its ranches this
New Mexico lawyer thinks it speaks
volumes but you think that the fact that
they still are pumping money and running
these ranches is a tell right what does
it tell us yeah I think it's a highly
suspicious activity there's no real
um
in any way reasonable explanation for
them to continuing to play the game of
ranch ownership and management up here
in White Pine County other than that
they are still somehow angling in the
future for a Toe Hold or a foothold to
allow them to take Rural Water
perskovitz was fighting cancer when he
prevailed over a battery of high-powered
lawyers employed by snwa records show
the agency has retained a long list of
expensive law firms to fight its various
battles the cows and sheep of the snwa
ranches have their very own lawyer
lobbyist who's paid six hundred thousand
dollars per year to represent them at
the Nevada legislature those legal costs
don't generally get included in the
financial statements of the Great Basin
Ranch statements which appear to show
the ranches operating in the black the
ranch spent Millions to buy all new
stock it spent Millions more on new
watering pivots to grow its Alfalfa an
impressive array of top-of-the-line
track actors and trucks new barns to
house all that hay unlike its smaller
neighbors this Ranch doesn't have to pay
a mortgage or property taxes or license
fees for its Vehicles boy if that's a
great neighbor I'm sure glad they
haven't been vindictive sheep Rancher
Hank Vogler has been in the crosshairs
of snwa ever since he came out opposed
to the pipeline plan although snwa vowed
to be a good neighbor when it bought the
seven ranches it's been embroiled in
multiple disputes with several of its
smaller Rivals expensive legal fights
over grazing rights that have drained
the wallets of family ranches already
strained by the drought records we
obtained from snwa show and ongoing
surveillance of Hank bogler and his
livestock the snwa ranch has filed
numerous complaints about bugler with
other government agencies that led to
investigations and more lawyer fees this
is what I spent my entire life trying to
do and now I'm trying to be shoved out
of business pushed aside destroyed by my
entire life savings is going down the
crapper
we wanted to ask snwa why they're using
public money to compete against private
businesses and why they're growing
Alfalfa but they declined to appear on
camera instead they responded to our
written questions we are posting those
on our website back to you